let's go to Chris from Iowa Chris
welcome to the program what is on your
mind today
Chris from Iowa please
can you hear me okay yes
wonderful okay so um
speaking of culture issues I think the
profession that has been affected the
most has been the teaching profession in
education in general um and so my
question is how do
um people who are in the profession
combat that without getting in trouble
or
um going against the grain I mean it
seems like there are times when teachers
just do not have a voice in what's going
on so in some sense it sounds like what
you're saying is teaching has become
unbearable for teachers because you've
got all these Kooks saying I want to
decide what books and material you're
teaching I want to decide how you're
teaching it I want to decide about masks
I want to decide about vaccines I don't
want this I don't want that is that
that's why the teaching has become so
difficult
yeah it's a lot of outside pressure and
noise
um and it also it becomes difficult
because it feels like we we don't have
real any really any power to do anything
about it other than keep just keeping
our heads down and doing our best
you're breaking up a little bit Chris
but here's here's the thing and I hate
that this is the reality
I think that teachers
can't do it on their own I think
teachers are going to need the support
at minimum at minimum of the teachers
unions and the principals and the
superintendents and probably of local
elected officials as well in order to be
able to establish we're not going to be
bullied by parents if you show up and
act out at a school board meeting or
whatever you're not going to get your
way that's not the way to actually have
your voice heard I I believe that
teachers need to be supported by all of
these different elements it can't just
be teachers going hey I'm going to teach
what I'm going to teach because the
truth is particularly in states that
have passed laws about these things
they'll just get fired they'll just get
fired and then that's not going to help
anybody particularly not the students so
I think it's going to take a team effort
okay well that helps a lot they
oh boy Chris's connection is a mess so
Chris from Iowa we're going to let you
go do appreciate hearing from you super
important issue